[FOOTSTEPS]
♪♪
Now we come to the end.
There's no way to pretend.
I can't do this anymore.
It's over, it's over, and done.
I gave all that I have through the good times and bad.
You don't want to say goodbye, but it's over, it's over,
and done.
I know that sometimes what we had it was good.
Sometimes life plays out just away then it should for us.
I swear I thought it could for us.
But I'm done holding your hand.
Holding your--
I pray you understand.
You understand.
No one wants to face the truth, but it's over, it's over,
it's over, it's over.
And now--
We come to the end.
Now we come to the end.
There's no way, no way, no way.
I know that we tried, we swallowed our pride.
Swallow our pride.
We've gone deep inside.
Gone deep inside.
We know that something has died.
It's over, it's over, it's over, it's over and done.
Over and done.
It's over and over and done.
It's over and done.